bowing could serve as a model for
companies looking to get back to work
thousands of the company's employees
were back on the job this week the
aerospace giant wants to resume
production of facilities in Washington
State Ohio and Pennsylvania the workers
are using new procedures to protect them
from coronavirus Kris Van Cleave reports
on how companies are trying to keep
workers safe signs welcome back some of
the 27,000 Boeing employees returning to
work this week in Washington State
they're finding a new normal of
temperature checks social distancing
enhanced cleaning procedures staggered
shifts to reduce crowding when people
arrive and leave required mask-wearing
and for workers who must be close
together they'll be issued PPE glad that
the Boeing Company is committing to very
robust social distancing protocols and
use of PPE Boeing says it will use
contact tracing should someone come down
with kovat 19 but some like this triple
7 mechanic are worried we jumping the
gun on this most of them are ready to
apprehend something and it's too soon
and they're worried be honestly they're
very worried for Boeing back to work
means filling orders and bringing in
much-needed revenue it's pretty clear
that people are gonna be looking at
Boeing and seeing what the results are
this is one of the many steps needed on
the road back to getting people working
again
General Motors employees volunteered to
come back to work building ventilators
requiring new procedures that if
successful could be valuable lessons
learned when it's time to restart car
production safety is our overriding
priority so we are following very strict
protocols as it relates to temperature
screening wearing masks there's cleaning
protocols from the starter ship from the
end of ship ford also has hundreds back
in factories building ventilators making
respirators and 3d printing face shields
how do you keep from getting each other
sick we have pre-screening in place we
will have physical separation for the
employees when making our own face
shield so we'll be we'll be using that
Boeing officials tell CBS News the
health and safety of their employees and
their families is the
money's priority and their measures are
based on federal and state guidance for
CBS this morning Saturday Kris Van
Cleave Washington